hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar understanding the how and the
why bio safety and centrifugation
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann culture life sciences
to learn more visit beckmann.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and this
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
bob rodriguez sales specialist at
beckmann coulter life sciences and dr
lori kalman professor of biotechnology
at montgomery college
welcome and you may now begin your
presentation
welcome to the talk understanding the
how and the why biosafety and
centrifugation
this document contains proprietary
information owned by beckmann coulter
and is not for distribution without
express written consent of beckmann
culture
all products
referred to are for research use only
unless specified for ivd use beckman
product and service content are
trademarks of beckmann coulter
all other trademarks are the property of
their owners
the views expressed here by laurie
kelman are her own
lori has not received compensation for
this webinar from beckmann coulter
centrifugation is an indispensable
laboratory application for separating
and purifying a range of biological
materials
although a cornerstone
gaps in general understanding of good
laboratory practices 21 cfr part 58
are not uncommon
and can serve to impede efficiencies
negatively impact research goals
and can even increase laboratory safety
risk factors
laurie
hi i'm lori kellman a professor of
biotechnology at the germantown campus
of
montgomery college in maryland
we prepare people for jobs in the local
biotech industry by providing hands-on
training in cell culture protein dna and
rna methods as well as introducing
students to the basics of glp and cgmp
in our bio manufacturing suite
and i am bob rodriguez with beckmann
coulter life sciences a sales specialist
on a variety of products including
centrifugation
the intent is to provide information to
assist with utilizing centrifugation in
a more productive and safe manner
these are our learning objectives for
the talk
and we're going to review the
fundamentals of centrifugation talk
about the basic use and maintenance of
centrifuges and discuss centrifuge
safety in general i'll be talking about
the how or probably what i'd like to
call centrifuge 101 and bob will be
telling you more about the why
the first part of the talk includes
fundamentals of centrifugation
lab centrifuges are not used in
isolation
if we work our way out from the center
of this diagram
samples are held in tubes or other
containers that have to be selected
based upon the appropriate rotor for the
application
the centrifuge itself is located within
the lab environment and all of these
choices from the tube selected to the
management of the laboratory can have
consequences for safety
certification is a technique for
separating particles in solution using
centrifugal force generated by a
spinning rotor
under this force directed outward from
the center of rotation
particles are separated by size and
density with larger and or denser or
higher mass particles moving faster
this force is opposed by a buoyant force
because these particles are displacing
solution volume as they travel and by
frictional force depending on how much
particle service is interacting with the
solution
each of these interactions are related
to analyte mass
volume and shape the most popular method
for separation by centrifuge is by
pelleting where all
or most of the particles are collected
at the bottom of the tube
simple pelleting collects all particles
and differential pelleting stops the run
while the smallest subpopulation is
still in suspension
this is done when the smallest particles
are being retained for downstream work
note the picture of the conical tube
with cells collected at the bottom using
simple pelleting
and note the diagram at the right
showing four time points where during
the run leading to time number four
where the run is stopped in order to
collect the smallest fraction still in
solution which has been separated from
the larger fractions which have pelleted
these are five centrifuge run and
environmental conditions which affect
the separation and safe operation when
using a centrifuge rotor speed and
imbalance potential are always a safety
consideration
ambient temperature will affect the
centrifuges ability to cool well
deceleration profiles are related to the
degree of unwanted mixing which can
occur when the break is applied
and centrifugation produces aerosol so
depending on the hazards that are
specific to your samples you may have to
take more than the regular precautions
there are two common rotor types
swinging bucket and fixed angle the
rotor pictured on the left is a swinging
bucket rotor where the bucket swings to
a horizontal plane during the spin
all particles move down the length of
the tube and when pelleting collect at
the bottom center of the tube
separations in a swinging bucket
take longer because the travel distance
taken by particles is longer than with a
fixed angle rotor
the swinging bucket rotors cannot be
spun as fast because they are top heavy
and hence more unstable
fixed angle rotors hold the tube at a
set angle from vertical
particles move outward diagonally across
the tube hit the outside wall and slide
down and are collected at the bottom
outside of the tube travel distance is
less so run times are less
and fixed angle rotors are more stable
so they can be spun faster which
decreases run times even more
what tube to use has more options than
any other centrifuge considerations and
some of these features relate to safety
issues
volume to be processed and product to be
collected are key considerations
performed by every user
but tube material reuse of tubes proper
adapters and the ability of the tube to
contain spills all affect biosafety and
should be considered
part two basic use and maintenance
your centrifuge must be correctly
installed and if you move a centrifuge
it has to be reinstalled and re-leveled
benchtop centrifuges should be located
away from the edge of a counter because
if it should move during a run it
shouldn't also fall off the bench and
cause a much more serious incident
load the centrifuge correctly
check that the latch is properly closed
by listening for a click with some
models and by re-checking with another
push on the lid
when operating a centrifuge remain near
the centrifuge as it comes up to speed
and pay attention for anything out of
the ordinary
if you hear an unusual sound or if you
feel an unusual vibration shut the spin
down
after a run inspect the inside of the
centrifuge and the rotor and clean both
cleaning is a critical step in
centrifuge maintenance and once this
becomes a habit it's really easy to do
i worked in two different labs where i
was considered a mechanical genius
because everybody thought i could fix
any piece of equipment but i have to put
air quotes around fix because all i
really did was clean the equipment
once a centrifuge was air quotes broken
because the lid wouldn't latch and you
know it wouldn't turn on
a really quick visual inspection showed
a piece of tape rather obviously stuck
in the latch mechanism i used forceps to
remove it and air quotes fixed the
centrifuge
the previous user of that centrifuge
should have noticed a label missing from
one of the samples and followed up and
found it but obviously they did not
i must add uh lori's story is a simple
but real world example of how common
sense and a little care
can eliminate many problems
the gravitational forces generated by a
spinning rotor can range from around one
thousand to over one hundred thousand
g's
one mil of water weighs one
gram at 1g
but 10 000 grams at 10 000 g's
as a result imbalances are magnified
leading to imbalance being one of the
biggest causes of accidents
under these stresses rotor materials
whether made of metal or carbon fiber
are stretched every time they are run
other common causes of rotor accidents
include little or no inspection of the
rotors for stress signs like cracks
sticking of buckets due to insufficient
cleaning
no or damaged o-rings
and weak or improperly sealed tubes
proper tube sealing is especially
critical when containing infectious
samples
depending on the biosafety level of your
samples you do have additional options
such as sealed rotors and filtering the
centrifuge exhaust
my centrifuges weren't used for the past
several months and bob reminded me
before we recorded this that i'd really
better take a good look at my o-rings
tube selection is complicated because
there are so many options
make sure you're using a tube
appropriate for the intended use the
tube should fit the rotor and this
sounds obvious but the force of
centrifugation doesn't allow for gaps or
movement with ill-fitting tubes
the shape of the tube needs to fit the
shape of the rotor cup
each tube should be inspected by eye
before you use it and there should not
be any visible cracks or stress marks
notice the red arrows in this diagram
because that's the direction of stress
for a spinning tube and that could be
where you'll see a crack
and if your rotor isn't clean a particle
left at the bottom of a rotor can cause
a star crack on the bottom of a reused
tube the caps of some tubes have
multiple parts make sure that you have
all the parts and you use them correctly
and make sure when you're balancing that
all the parts are present deformed tubes
or caps should not be used and the best
practice is just to discard centrifuge
tubes that can't be used in a centrifuge
when in doubt throw it out you've got
too much junk in that drawer anyway and
leaving those tubes around really just
asks for somebody to use a tube that
shouldn't be used
uh know the g limit for the tube and do
not exceed it
consider solvent compatibility and make
sure the tubes that you use are made of
a compatible material
if you need to sterilize the bottles use
the correct procedure i'm sure bob can
tell you stories i know i can about
collapsed and deformed bottles due to
incorrect autoclaving
and properly fill tubes or bottles never
overfill them
some of them have to be filled to work
but don't overfill split your sample
into more tubes if necessary
i also regarding tubes have a quick tube
story
one of our ultra centrifuge rotor spins
1.5 mil microfuge tubes at speeds that
generate up to 186 000 g's
several times i have received calls from
users complaining that all of their
tubes were crushed during a run
i had to tell them that only our
microcentrifuge tube is rated for forces
up to 186 000 g's all other tubes that i
know of are rated for forces no higher
than 30 000 g's
balancing tubes is really important and
here's where your laboratory environment
matters
an electronic balance should be
conveniently located near your
centrifuge or the sample prep area you
shouldn't have to walk all over the lab
to find it
weigh your tubes with the caps and after
also weigh them after carefully wiping
off any ice or liquid from the outside
of the tube a rule of thumb for
balancing tubes is they should be within
0.2 grams of each other
wipe the tube off again before you load
it into the rotor and i know this should
be obvious but ice crystals and water
have mass and ice crystals melt into
liquid that can dirty your rotor
loading the rotor involves placing
balanced tubes diagonally and directly
across from each other
for fixed angle rotors this is often
pretty straightforward but the image at
the bottom of this slide shows swinging
buckets with multiple samples and these
can be confusing to load remember i
teach people who have not used
centrifuges before you want to draw a
straight line
from one tube through the spindle
straight across to the balance tube
notice the incorrectly loaded mirror
images here a properly loaded bucket
they're not mirror images
best practice is to have another person
check the loaded rotor before you start
the run and it is never a waste of time
to ask if you have a question about
safety do not start a centrifuge if
you're not sure that your tubes are
balanced and the rotor is loaded
properly
it's also best practice to spread the
load evenly around the rotor rather than
concentrate it directly across from each
other
every rotor is designed to be spun at a
maximum speed but after years of use and
stress
the rotor material does not have the
elasticity of when it was new
older rotors should be inspected either
by trained lab personnel
or by the rotor manufacturer
in general the maximum speed of old
rotors should be reduced or derated by
10 percent
this is related to the run speed
selected and whether that speed exceeds
what is safe
note though
that higher speed centrifuges have over
speed detection features to prevent
rotors from exceeding their speed limits
but it is still good practice to follow
rotor speed limits especially with older
rotors
another safety related practice is to be
aware during early rotor acceleration of
excessive vibrations which is a sign of
an imbalance
if this happens stop the run
centrifuges have imbalance detection
features but at times do not pick up
imbalances quick enough to prevent a
costly accident
when i start a run i put my hand on the
centrifuge to feel for the vibration and
i also listen to the centrifuge as it
comes up to speed
there's a normal vibration and a little
bit of a wobble around 700 or 800 rpm
but then the vibration settles as the
speed increases
if that does not happen or if you hear
an unusual sound shut the run down
immediately
i learned a new thing while preparing
for this bob told me the name of that
vibration or wobble
and i've forgotten what it's called it's
called procession
procession right and it's normal on a
centrifuge but if it gets worse after
that that is not normal
lori and i have discussed why
centrifuges are used as a separation
tool
but here i will outline why there are
many centrifuge types
i have explained that centrifuges
separate based on size and density or
mass
g-force causes particles to move but
large and heavier mass particles move
faster
in biology mammalian cells are
relatively large at approximately 10
microns in diameter
they can be pelleted at approximately 2
000 g's in a few minutes so a low speed
bench centrifuge like the one pictured
above on the left is sufficient
however
smaller particles like bacteria and
subcellular organelles move slower so
they need higher speeds and forces
typically in the 10 000 to 50 000 g
force range to pellet them in
approximately 10 to 30 minutes
the centrifuges in the middle above are
used for these applications
very small particles like viruses move
the slowest so they require forces
typically over a hundred thousand g's
generated by an ultra centrifuge to move
fast enough to perform a separation in
approximately two hours so the size and
or mass of a particle to be separated
dictates the best type of centrifuge to
be used
part three
safety considerations
when people teach centrifugation
we often use the example of the spin
cycle on a washing machine
and while that uses centrifugal force to
remove water from your towels it's
really a terrible example because the
force involved is so much less than what
we use in laboratories
i teach new centrifuge users and it's my
observation that many high schools have
tabletop microcentrifuges the little
ones that spin 1.5 mil flip top tubes
even these don't generate the forces
involved in floor model centrifuges
the forces involved in centrifugation
it's not within our experience and so
it's really difficult to imagine be sure
that you get training because what
applies to a microfuge like balancing
tubes by eye is not how to work with
other centrifuges
what this
slide is showing is that the cap of a
pen if subjected to 1 million g
it would effectively turn into the
weight of a small car that's the kind of
force we're talking about and that's why
balancing and loading a centrifuge is so
critically important
and this is also why a centrifuge which
might not seem to do a lot except make a
little bit of noise while it's running
can cause the occasional catastrophic
laboratory accident
many rotor accidents are caused by user
error and hence are avoidable
and as just discussed the forces
generated in a centrifuge can create
considerable damage
and even an unsafe event to those near
the centrifuge
above on the left is a picture of a
rotor accident in an ultra centrifuge
where the rotor made of titanium was
obliterated
proper centrifuge rotor and tube care
can greatly reduce these incidents
however note that this particular
incident occurred over 30 years ago
ultra centrifuges today have better
imbalance detection features to prevent
many of these incidents from happening
the picture on the right shows corrosion
highlighted by a die in an aluminum
fixed angle rotor
aluminum is the most common material
used in low and high speed rotors
routine rinsing of salt deposits
accumulated in the rotor wells as part
of a regular rotor maintenance
can prevent this and ensure safer
operation
i've never been in a lab at the moment
where there was a catastrophic rotor
incident but i've been in several labs
after there was and i will agree with
bob these this was decades ago uh in one
case the rotor was old and the lab knew
there was a chance that this would
happen eventually and it did uh that
particular lab did a lot of ultra
centrifugation and it did not derate
their rotors but used them to failure
again knowing at some point that the
rotor would fail
another incident
that i'm aware of was due to operator
error the samples were not properly
balanced and in this case the centrifuge
was lost and of course the samples were
lost at the same time
i was also in a lab where a balancing
error led to a spindle on the centrifuge
that stretched out basically into a very
very long piece of wire we were not
exactly sure how that happened i'm sure
bob could explain it
and i've personally witnessed a number
of runs that had to be aborted
all of these were due to either
balancing problems failing to seat the
rotor correctly or failing to check that
the swinging buckets could swing freely
in other words they were all due to
operator
error in the united states federal
agencies provide regulatory guidelines
on safety
but interpretation and compliance falls
on the individual organization
and requires proactive engagement in
order to maintain compliance
the role of the organization's
eh s group combined with the individual
lab is to train for and enact good
practice
and to refresh and review these
practices regularly
thus in the u.s
regulatory compliance is comprehensive
but falls across multiple organizations
whereas in other regions of the globe
such as europe the approach is to
maintain all regulatory comment under
one organization
however at this time that regulatory
comment is incomplete
in a biologics development or production
setting safety is embedded into the
operation through various risk
mitigation activities such as regular
centrifuge and rotor maintenance
and routine training
the centrifuge and rotor maker build
safety into its operation by considering
the centrifuge rotor and labware as a
system from early design through
manufacturing with the primary objective
to ensure safety even in the event of a
severe accident
if you work in labs long enough there's
a chance that you're going to witness or
hear of centrifugation incidents i've
described a couple of them already
in my experience nearly all of them were
due to human error
also in my experience
in none of them was anybody injured and
that's really a testament to the
centrifugation industry and part of why
i think centrifuge safety isn't really
front of mind
but losing a centrifuge
you're going to lose your sample it's
going to stop work in the laboratory and
it's a very expensive incident and so we
should all be aiming for 100 centrifuge
safety all the time
the code of federal regulations cfr
codifies the rules issued by the
agencies of the federal government
section 42 cfr 73 relates to the
possession and use of various viruses
including
sars kovi
where registrants must develop and
implement a written biosafety plan to be
reviewed annually describing the
biosafety and containment procedures
part
73.12 calls in part specifically for
quote centrifuge safety containers
unquote to protect lab personnel
and the public
the international electric technical
commission or iec sets standards
globally for the performance and safety
of electrical products
lab equipment and manufacturers like
those that make centrifuges belong to
this commission
a section within these standards deals
with centrifuge lab safety where
guidelines are set for the testing of
new centrifuge and rotor systems another
thing i learned while preparing for this
presentation i didn't know that there
was an iec i i had no idea so thank you
for that uh i really want the course on
how centrifuges are tested bob
i might also add uh
they are literally tested and um and
exploded in a block house so um and this
is uh
this is per iec guidelines
the centrifuge lab safety guideline and
here it is iec 61010-2-020
calls for the testing of the ability of
a new centrifuge to contain a severe
rotor accident which it terms a maximum
credible accident
and i might add that in this case here
the manufacturer must take its most
explosive potential rotor and and
literally damage it so that it comes
apart during an over speed run to be
able to test the ability of that
centrifuge to contain that explosion
the passing of this test means that the
centrifuge prevented or contained very
small particles from falling
over one meter from the centrifuge
and acceptance of this test data leads
to certification by safety organizations
such as underwriters labs
csa and ce
beckman coulter has been a stakeholder
in the iec for decades
one really important practice is
whenever you start a centrifuge you
should know exactly how to shut it down
press the stop button turn the speed to
zero turn the time to zero
you need to know how to do that before
you press the start button panicking is
bad when something goes wrong
and once you do that step away from the
centrifuge i'm glad to know it probably
will be contained but you know better
safe than sorry
on many research lab protocols the
centrifugation step is just this short
one-line instruction and i think that
gives the false impression that the
centrifuge step is going to be quick
in addition when your sample's spinning
that's often a chance for you to finally
have a snack or take a break or or do
something else and in my observation
getting samples into the centrifuge is
often a rushed step
please take your time an incident may
not only cause you to use your sam lose
your sample but also to lose a really
expensive piece of lab equipment and of
course there's also the chance of injury
check and recheck as you balance and
load your centrifuge
tube leaks and rotor accidents often
occur because attention has not been
given to the condition of tubes and
rotors
check tubes for cracks and for proper
seals if they are sealed
tube and bottle cracks especially if
they are reused
often start at the bottom and either run
around the circumference at the bottom
or up the sides as shown in this slide
use manuals or manufacture website or
product support to learn good practice
for rotor balancing
where regular lubrication is needed how
to clean and disinfect rotors
rotor imbalance allowances can be as low
as laurie has indicated as
0.2 grams for some ultra centrifuge
rotors
and up to 10 grams for large volume
high-speed rotors
accidents can also occur when rotors are
not attached securely to the centrifuge
or when the rotor is missing a critical
part such as a lid
i must add also o-rings missing o-rings
is another cause for uh all kinds of
different centrifuge problems
requests that the manufacturer inspect
all rotors to identify rotors that
should be retired due to defects i'll
add a couple of my observations
knowing for example that your bottles
can be 10 grams apart doesn't mean that
you should be aiming for that
remember if any liquid is on it or ice
crystals that's going to change the mass
of it so please always be closer to
zero difference rather than saying yeah
it's probably okay that word probably
okay really makes me worry
in addition
if you're cleaning your centrifuge on a
regular basis and inspecting it you're
going to notice those o-rings that maybe
came loose during a run
when safety is a priority a worker won't
feel that they have to rush through a
protocol
the lab should be set up with
best practice in mind
for example having a convenient place to
balance tubes
budget enough time for the work to be
done and take the time to do things
right
carpenters say measure twice and cut
once and i'm going to say balance twice
well i don't really say that but be sure
and be confident before you load a rotor
if you aren't sure which tubes are the
balanced pairs weigh them again if you
aren't sure how to use a centrifuge or
any piece of equipment ask and if you
forget ask again
safety is the result
as we've heard here today of
well-designed and maintained tools such
as centrifuges combined with good
practice to reduce risk
oversight bodies provide guidance
but it is the responsibility of the
organization
to implement monitor and maintain safety
standards
for this reason safety is not applied
universally but is a practice customized
for each
organization thank you for your
attention we're happy to take your
questions
thank you bob and lori for your
informative presentation we'll take a
moment for our speakers to grab a sip of
water and in the meantime we would like
to understand our audience better i will
now share a series of poll questions and
your participation is greatly
appreciated our first question is
would you like beckman coulter life
sciences to conduct a free rotor
inspection
i'll give you about
15 seconds to respond
next
is does your organization have an eh s
department who might be interested in
learning more about biosafety and
centrifugation
next i would like to feel a little safer
about biosafety please have my local bec
ls representative reach out to me to
discuss options
and the last poll question
um what webinar topics would you like to
see from beckman coulter i.e product
applications
techniques and methods
research areas industry standards etc
please be specific
all right
well we'll now start the live q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what is the best course of action i can
take to assess centrifuge safety in my
lab is this process something that
beckman coulter can help us with
um hello can you hear me yes okay great
uh yes thank you um
that really is a conversation that uh
should be had depending on the the types
of ques the types of centrifuges and the
types of rotors that you use
[Music]
as mentioned during the talk
centrifuges range from very low speed uh
bench top models all the way up to uh
floor model ultra centrifuges the forces
great uh vary greatly the types of
rotors vary greatly types of labware
very greatly so really that's a
discussion that should be had between
uh someone like myself or someone um
within the company uh and and the lab
all right thank you
um next question
how do you inspect a rotor and how do
you clean it
uh
i'll uh i'll continue that laura you can
um you can enter in if uh uh
if you have a comment i'm just gonna say
i mostly just look at it and clean it
with water but i know you'll do a better
job of answering this
yeah in general metal rotors uh should
be rinsed out
uh with um uh
di water with a soft brush
uh the the issue with rotors often is
salt deposits at the bottom of the well
which cake up and and may cause
corrosion problems with aluminum rotors
so our recommendation is to watch that
and to remove that salt
through this rinsing process
and then at the end after
a good flush
turn the rotor upside down to let it air
dry so that's basic rotor maintenance
right there
but also good
maintenance or good ideas on um or
rather a good procedure on how to treat
every rotor uh just keep them clean
yeah and i'll add to that about the
laboratory uh environment
if you've got the sort of rotor where it
would really help to have a flashlight
to be able to see if you've got some
white salt deposits at the bottom then
it would be really nice to have that
flashlight handy
correct
i might add also uh that look first
small cracks um
especially with swinging bucket rotors
where the buckets hinge onto the rotor
body
uh look for little micro cracks
certainly the first signs that the rotor
is starting to um
to age and should be replaced so that's
especially in swinging bucket rotors but
also in
fixed angle rotors this is where a good
light will help to shine down into the
well and look for any
any areas where
cracks may be occurring
all right great thank you
um our next question what about pan
balances for balancing is that okay
i'll start with that one
personally i'm not a fan of pan balances
but for centrifuges that are not
ultra centrifuges they're really fine
it's just in my experience sometimes
they stick a little
and i'm never 100 sure they're they're
working the way they should i don't know
what it is i think i like the comfort of
seeing the numbers on the electronic
balance but i think that's personal to
me
yeah i might add also that uh
we have um
tolerances
for each type of centrifuge so really
the the balance requirements as as
uh spoken during the talk
differ
depending on the type of rotor how fast
it's run
and so that's going to dictate how
careful you should be
with balance but balance is a big issue
balances
along with human error probably the the
biggest reasons why uh centrifuges fail
okay
um next question
do you clean a rotor after every use
so i inspect it after every use
i i don't
truly clean it after every use but if
there's any reason it needs to be
cleaned it gets cleaned and that's the
moment to do it because it's going to
take a little while to dry so if you
wait to clean it until right before
you're about to use it you can't use it
right away
i would add that uh shouldn't have to do
that that that's uh um adds a lot of
time to um the what needs to be done in
the lab
really i think the eyeball there can
tell you whether that needs to be done
because tubes leak bottles leak
you can often see
that there's been a spill or even a
minor spill
so that might require a quick rinse and
a rotor to take care of
the other telltale sign is what's at the
bottom of the centrifuge chamber um if
there's been a bad leak you'll see it so
of course after something like that wipe
that up but i would say
a good practice is just to keep an eye
out for when that is needed but you
shouldn't have to do that every run or
even
i i think it's better just to set in a
regular practice every week for instance
uh check on the various things that need
to be checked
all right thank you um next question is
there somewhere that i can find
information on chemical compatibility
and o-rings
uh yes um at the back of our rotor
catalogs we have a chemical
compatibility charts certainly you're
welcome to contact me or or those in the
company who can help you there
o-rings are specific to each rotor
so again the catalog is the best place
to go to the rotor page the particular
rotor page of interest
and it will contain the the o-ring
information
keep in mind also uh there are often
multiple o-rings with a rotor so
just
make sure you are looking at
all the o-rings that need to be replaced
all right
next question can i just use volume of
the same solution in the same type of
tube
to balance instead of weight
so i'm going to say no
for a micro-centrifuge
you know a tabletop microcentrifuge
sure balancing by eye is is probably
good enough
once you get to something that's going
to generate more force please balance by
weight i know some people who do work uh
with things like um
deuterium
and
balancing by eye if you've got water and
something with heavy isotopes in it
that's not gonna work
um
[Music]
and
bob you probably have something to add
to that
yes and during the talk laura and i both
talked about how g-force multiplies the
mass of what you are spinning and that's
the thing to keep in mind is
how much mass is being spun
at the the forces that are being applied
and then uh think of that as a
multiplier so any differences between
one side and the other side of the rotor
are multiplied by that the amount of g's
that are being
uh applied to that spin
so um so that's really the thing to keep
in mind is what is that difference and
minimize that difference certainly to
win within tolerances but even better
than that if you can
all right
and this is more of a comment that maybe
you would like to
add to it
in clinical labs it is a good idea to
keep a log do you have any any comments
you'd like to add to that
i do um just when i was listening to to
what we just said i realized we forgot
to mention log books
uh you can't de-rate a rotor for example
if you don't if you haven't kept a log
book because you won't know how often
you know how much you've used that rotor
yes i'm a huge believer in log books
and if you're going to use a log book
everybody has to use the log book you
can't go well this is only a five minute
spin
so
yeah i'm a fan
yeah the thing to keep in mind with
rotors uh
and again this was mentioned during the
talk that during a spin the rotor
actually stretches
and at the end of the spin it relaxes
and that that process is called a cycle
so our our concern is how many cycles
has that rotor been exposed to during
its lifetime
and that's what the log books are all
about is trying to keep track of how
many cycles to to understand
when that rotor should be replaced
because the
the rotors don't re don't return
their elasticity is not the same when
they are old as when they were new so as
a result over time that rotor is slowly
deforming and and so that's why uh the
cycle count is important however cycle
cycle the number of cycles and how to
track that
is is often tough as busy as labs are so
what we often do is we try to estimate
how many cycles
per month per year
and then during its lifetime uh and
that's what gives us an understanding
combined with the age of whether that
rotor should be replaced
all right thank you
next question we are looking to have an
oq performed for our centrifuge to
assess speed
do you recommend an oqb performed
annually or would there be another
annual service besides the routine pm
uh i would uh i would again point to uh
the regulatory requirements for your lab
your department your organization
uh in this oq setting if it's a gmp
setting
often there are
internal corporate um
timelines that need to be met with
regard to gmp sops
so that really is specific to the
organization
um
uh a uh
an oq
for a centrifuge um uh calibrates a
speed uh time and and temperature
uh and it really is something that does
not need to be done uh very often
my suggestion would be maybe six months
possibly a year again depending on
corporate uh requirements
but
that's something to discuss internally
as to how often that needs to be done
the only time i would say
an oq needs to be redone is when that
centrifuges moved
alright thank you
next question
i am having trouble getting small pieces
of hay
approximately one millimeter ground
to form a solid pellet in water do you
recommend increasing the time or the
force first when coming up with new
centrifuging conditions
so i'll
stab at that um
the answer is i don't know the answer
but as someone who used to work on
plants
i'm wondering if your hay isn't buoyant
if it either doesn't have some trapped
air in it or um
[Music]
or it's just less dense and not gonna
pell it so well
um
you said small
it's gonna depend on what you're trying
to do there and i'd be happy to try to
answer you more personally by email if
you want did you have any thoughts on
that bob
yes and you hit it laurie um it's it
really the separation is relative to the
difference in density
between the particle and the solvent
which in this case is probably water
so um if
a particle is close to water in its
specific gravity it's it's going to be a
difficult
uh separation and there are times with
an oil lipids for instance and on the
clinical side classic example of lipids
being less dense so uh in a centrifuge
lipids will float and actually that's
taken advantage of uh in various
centrifuge
separations
yeah if if you want those um if you want
the little hay particles you may wind up
having to do a a buoyant
step gradient kind of
centrifugation step
[Music]
okay thank you
next question what will be the general
rpm of the rotor why is 0.2 g so
important
okay i'll i'll take first shot at that
0.2 is is a tough uh i know
it's not much of a difference but again
keep in mind
that 0.2
uh relates in in usually to swinging
bucket rotors uh ultra centrifuge
swinging bucket rotors which have forces
well over 100 000 g's so that zero point
two times a hundred thousand now is
significant so that's what we're saying
is uh it really depends on uh the force
applied uh uh and
combined with that differential that
weight difference and that will tell you
how important it is to be able to um
uh to uh
to balance each side
uh so and again
i made the comment during the um the
talk that swinging bucket rotors are top
heavy so they are less stable so that
also adds to why that tolerance is so
low but that point two doesn't relate to
uh many of the lower speed rotors so
you'll find again in the um
in the manuals or by talking to us what
that tolerance is it may go to a gram or
even higher depending on what the speed
is and what the rotor is
all right thank you
next question
can you use 70 alcohol to clean the
centrifuge chamber
um so the thing about alcohol is
it it is a disinfectant so if your goal
is to disinfect you could use that
it's also a different solvent than water
my recommendation and bob will correct
me if i'm wrong about this is you start
with water i'm assuming most of what
you're doing is aqueous so your first
solvent is going to be water uh the
other re so
water possibly followed by the 70
alcohol and then maybe you're
disinfecting the other thing the alcohol
will do is it will
help things dry a little faster but in
that case i'm calling it just kind of
speeding up the drying step anything to
add bob
uh yes and again i see that just like
you do as two steps first is cleaning
then disinfection if that's a
requirement
70 is as high an alcohol content as i
would recommend that's actually what our
recommendation is to disinfect uh bleach
is also another disinfectant but that's
uh i would say i think it's a five
percent bleach solution that we
recommend there keep in mind though
bleach will bleach uh the your rotor and
it will whiten it over time but that's
not a not a structural problem it's just
more of a cosmetic issue but 70 if
that's what you're using as a
disinfectant it's fine
yeah and i'll add any time you use five
percent bleach you have to then clean
with 100 water to make sure you uh
remove any of the residue from the
bleach
great thank you um
next question
regarding balancing loads for swing
bucket centrifuge when placing tubes was
the picture shown in your slide
the one on the left and okay loading
so this is when i'm really sorry that i
i can't
point to things at this moment
um
the
the swinging bucket multiple
15 mil or 50 mil centrifuge tube buckets
those are like the hardest things again
remembering i'm i'm showing newbies how
to do it
and
so if you picture
upper left upper right lower left lower
right so basically a little square
upper left upper right lower left lower
right
when you put a tube in the upper left
of one of the buckets
your balance tube for that one will be
in the upper left
of the other bucket and upper left is
you are standing at the spindle and
looking at the container
so they're diagonally across
what i tend to see people do
is i think they forget that you have to
like be the spindle to look at the
bucket and so they'll put it in the
upper left
on one bucket but then they'll wind up
putting it i think it would be the lower
left position on the other one it's not
balanced the other thing is with those
little multi-holder thingies
um sometimes you have to give them a
tiny little rotation so that
they're directly across from each other
bob if you have a better way to
accomplish
i like i like the idea of uh of the
viewpoint being from the center um of
the rotor but um
uh the in the slide i just looked at it
the uh the the uh diagram on the left is
a symmetrical one and the one on the
right
is the one that is an improper loading
so that really what you're looking for
is just symmetry
um keep in mind that um um depending uh
you know
let's say a dozen rotors excuse me a
dozen tubes on one side isn't
necessarily symmetrical with a dozen
tubes on the other side
number one you have to consider the
volumes and the volume differences hence
the weight differences and number two
it's the symmetry and so you really
place the tubes uh to be able to be
symmetrical with the other side
okay thank you um next question do
rotors need to be replaced even with no
signs of damage and if so how often
good question um
replacement of a rotor is dependent on
two things
um just explain actually cycles how many
cycles has that rotor been exposed to
and and if not if that cannot be
determined how old is it and then
from age you estimate how many cycles
and then the other part of it is
condition so that's where the visual
inspection comes in and i believe one of
the poll questions had to do with uh our
inspecting centrifuges and rotors this
is what we do during an
inspection is we literally look down
into every well or into every bucket and
we're looking and we're doing this with
magnified
um telescopes
that are well lit to be able to look at
the micro cracks that might be created
over time
that
that are telltale signs that this rotor
is starting to literally come apart
so um so it's really a combination of
age slash cycles
and condition and from that we make a
recommendation
all right thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question
is there a good book on the market that
you recommend about the centrifuge
techniques
specifically about the centrifuge can
you bob that's i feel like this is why
we're doing this
we have um
a a manual that has really not changed
much for a while
that we call uh our
rotor and tubes user guide
and it we can certainly send it to
anybody who's interested in it it's a
good
overview of all the different techniques
uh all the different types of rotors
actually it includes
a good section about the tubes so it's i
i would say a good place to start to see
if this satisfies what you're looking
for and then of course come to one of us
in beckman if
you would like to discuss it more or
need more
excuse me all right thank you bob and
lori and do you have any final comment
for our audience
uh really my only final comment is if
there's any more questions we'll try to
answer them by email
but thank you everyone for your time and
attention
likewise thank you all for attending
well thank you again bob and lori for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor beckman coulter life
sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye